catholic school called holy rosie across
some small police department in the fire
hall
and everybody that i grew up with either
became a cop a firefighter or a priest
i wasn't qualified for any of them so
here i am
but uh i admire the hell out of all of
you i really do it's not i'm not being
solicitous i mean it sincerely
and uh to the many parents spouses
brothers sisters who have to bury a
piece of their soul
in the deep earth it's really tough
stuff
it's hard as hell you all know it
to lose a colleague to lose a son a
daughter husband wife
and i want to thank
if they're not many here but i want to
thank all the spouses
of every one of you
or your significant other because every
time you pin that shield on and walk out
the door
they're worried where they're going to
get that phone call
get that phone call
too many have gotten the phone call
lately
and
every day in this country
uh
316 people are shot
106 are killed
and six nypd officers have been victims
of gun violence so far just this year
the same in the town north of me
philadelphia and my much smaller town of
wilmington delaware washington d.c
64 children
injured by gun violence so far this year
26 killed
it's enough enough is enough because we
know we can do things about this but for
the resistance we're getting from some
sectors of the government and the
congress and
the state legislatures and the
organizational structures out there
you know
mayor adams you and i agree
the answer is not to abandon our streets
that's not the answer the answer is to
come together
police and communities building trust
and making us all safer the answer is
not to defund the police
it's to give you the tools the training
the funding
to be partners to be protectors and
community needs you and know the
community you know
police
[Applause]
policing that treats everyone with
respect and dignity that's why i called
on the congress to pass a budget
later this year that provides cities
like new york
and others with an additional 300
million dollars for community policing
you know
where the police interact with the
community get to know the community
build trust in the community and i've
noticed in my experience when i wrote
the first crime bill i noticed that you
know i don't hear many communities no
matter what their color their background
saying i don't want more protection in
my community
i don't know i haven't found one of
those yet
and so i've asked the congress to
provide 200 million to invest in
community violence intervention programs
as well they work
they work
where community members with credibility
work directly with people they're most
likely to commit crimes or be victims of
gun crimes and they work
for example in 2017 the program i'm
going to see this afternoon
which sends people to the community in
the community to interrupt violence to
mediate conflicts to de-escalate succeed
in preventing single a a single shooting
from occurring in this largest public
housing development last year no
shooting for a full year
because they engage directly
with the community
you know i know this is a priority for
senator schumer which you all are doing
here i if i hear one more call from him
that we need more money for housing and
more money for cops i don't know i'm
going to send them back to you
but
but all kidding aside
this is uh this is a half a billion
dollars of proven strategies and we know
will reduce crime
congress needs to do its job to pass the
budget every one of these folks here and
come from congress are all supportive
but you know it's time to fund
communities community police
and the people who are going to protect
them
look as i said we're not about defunding
we're about funding and providing the
additional services you need beyond
someone with a gun strapped to their
shoulder to their head
we need more social workers we need more
mental health workers we need more
people when you're called on these
scenes and someone's about to jump off a
roof it's not just someone standing
there with a
someone who also knows how to talk to
people talk them down
we can't expect you to do every single
solitary thing that needs to be done to
keep the community safe
it's time to fund community policing to
protect and serve the community
and so i'm also calling for increased
funding for the bureau of alcohol
tobacco and firearms and the u.s
marshals offices i'm confident that we
fund these programs we'll see a
reduction in violence
and the next year's budget i'm also
going to try to double down on this
investment i think i got a lot of
partners here in new york going to help
mayor adams you say that gun violence is
a sea fed by many rivers
well
you know i put forward a plan to dam up
some of those streams
uh
you know you can count on me to be a
partner in that effort and i have the
u.s attorney
united states attorney general here with
me today
and we put together a comprehensive
strategy to combat gun crime in cities
like new york philadelphia atlanta and
many other cities san francisco
first
we want to crack down on the flow of
firearms you need to commit violence
that includes taking on and shutting
down
rogue gun dealers
at uh and it's it's about doing
background checks as well as outright
selling uh
that
making sure that people who are not
allowed to have a gun
don't get the gun in the first place and
again
for any of the press any depressed
listing this doesn't violate anybody's
second amendment right
there's no violation of a second
amendment right we talk like there's no
amendment it's absolute when the
amendment was passed it didn't say
anybody can own a gun and any kind of
gun and any kind of weapon
you couldn't buy a cannon
and when the this this uh amendment was
passed and so no reason why should be
able to buy certain assault weapons but
that's another issue
and uh look
one of the things that we focused on the
attorney general and i we're getting to
the point where i think we're going to
be able to have a real impact on it
includes going after ghost guns
ghost guns are the guns everyone in this
room knows that can be purchased in
parts
assembled at home
no serial number and can't be traced
and they're as deadly as any other
weapon out there but the fact is there's
they are out there
and
you know this spring the justice
department this spring the justice
department will issue a final rule to
regulate these so-called ghost cons
but there's more we can do
across the country police departments
report sharp increases in the number of
ghost guns found at crime scenes
that's why today the department is
launching an intestine and intensified
national ghost gun enforcement
initiative to determine and deter
criminals from using those weapons to
cover their tracks if you commit a crime
to the ghost gun not only are state and
local prosecutors going to come after
you but expect federal charges on
federal prosecution as well
we've also created a strike force to
crack down on legal gun trafficking
across state lines
as the mayor said as he pointed out
guns that are used to kill people in new
york city they aren't made in new york
city they aren't sold in new york city
they are sold in other places today the
attorney general directed all u.s
attorneys in the united states to
prioritize combating gun trafficking
across state lines and city boundaries
the justice department is sending
additional prosecutorial resources to
help shut down what's referred to as you
all know the iron pipeline that funnels
guns from shops in states like george to
the crime scenes in baltimore and
philadelphia and new york and so many
other places
governor you worked with the mayor and
the nypd
and nine other states to create an
interstate task force
uh on illegal guns
that's the kind of leadership that's
going to solve the problem and let me
get to hear more about that progress
and folks
second thing i want to point out is i
want to help every major city follow new
york's lead
put together partnerships like this one
you put together and meet in a daily
basis
every day here in new york city like
this meeting today federal state and
local enforcement meet to share
intelligence about arrests
shootings from the day before and work
to take those shooters off the street as
quickly as possible
just look around
this was the partnership looks like
and this is what you put together
and it's an important partnership we
need more cities adopting the same model
that's why today the attorney general is
also directing u.s attorneys to work
with state and local law enforcement
strength to strengthen partnerships like
this one and to get repeat gun violence
offenders off the street and behind bars
you know i want more cities and states
to use some of the 350 billion dollars
we sent to them
on the american rescue plan
to fight crime to keep our communities
safe by hiring more police officers for
community policing and paying police
overtime
and purchasing gun fighting technologies
like the technology that hears
locates gunshots so there can be
immediate response because you know
exactly where it came from
the third thing our plan calls for
investing in critical services that
reduce crime and violence
community violence intervention programs
like the one i'm going to see after this
meeting
summer school
after school programs for teens as the
saying goes the
teacher taught me idle mind is the
devil's workshop
we got to have things for these kids to
do
jobs for young adults more school
counselors and nurses
more mental health required in school
and mental health substance abuse
treatment as well
fourthly with someone when someone
finishes their time in prison
all our experience tells us you just
can't continue to give them 25 bucks on
a bus ticket they'll end up under the
same bridge you arrested them in the
first place from
and so i don't want i don't want them
ending up back in prison or being there
because they've committed another crime
we need to be able to train
for and get a job
find stable housing
re re-enter society and have a second
chance at a better life
my department of labor is funding
programs that help formally incarcerated
individuals including young adults
receive the education and training they
need and then connect them to quality
jobs
i'll keep doing everything in my power
to make sure the communities are safer
but congress needs to do its part too
pass universal background checks ban
assault weapons high-capacity magazines
close loopholes to keep out of the hands
of domestic abusers weapons repeal a
liability shield for gun manufacturers
imagine had we had a liability they're
the only industry in america
that is exempted from being able to be
sued by the public
only one
imagine had that been the way with
cigarette manufacturers where the hell
would we where would the heck would we
be
we'd be in tough shape why gun
manufacturers
because of the power of their lobbying
ability it's got to end
and they got to be held responsible for
the things that they do that are
irresponsible and folks you know it's
the only industry in america that i said
that's exempt from being sued
and i think i find it to be outrageous
and folks
these laws if we were able to pass and
we're going to save lives
and more equally importantly help you
protect one another and protect yourself
put law enforcement in a more a safer
circumstance we have an opportunity to
come to get together and fulfill the
first responsibility of government and
our democracy
to keep each other safe
so i want to thank you all there's much
more to say but i probably already said
so too much because a lot of people are
going to speak
but let's get this done let's get this
done
and god bless the men and women who put
their lives in line every single day to
keep our communities safe now i'm going
to turn it over with your permission to
the attorney general attorney general
garland
general
thank you president biden
as the president said the justice
department is doubling down on the fight
to protect our communities from violent
crime and from the gun violence that
often drives it
but we are not doing this work alone
as the president also said
what you see in this room represents the
core of our efforts
our partnerships which are essential to
success in disrupting violent crime
yesterday when the president and i spoke
with the mayor
on the telephone
the mayor talked about the importance of
the excellent cooperation he is seeing
between the city state and federal law
enforcement agencies who are represented
here
at the justice department we know that
the best anti-violent crime strategies
are tailored to the needs of
and are developed by
and in partnership with
individual communities
that is why all of our justice
department law enforcement agencies
and all 94 of our united states
attorney's offices
including the two represented by the
united states attorneys who are here
today
are working with their partners in state
and local law enforcement to develop and
implement district specific anti-violent
crime policies
we also know that while many of the
public safety challenges our cities face
require this tailored approach
gun violence is a universal challenge
and one that demands comprehensive
action
that is why as the president said the
justice department is taking action to
crack down on ghost guns
and to hold those who illegally sell
firearms to criminals
accountable
that is why we are strengthening our
firearms trafficking strike forces
to disrupt the pipeline that floods our
community with illegal guns
and that is why we are sparing no
resource in identifying and holding
accountable the repeat offenders who are
the major drivers of violent crime
as we work in partnership with state and
local law enforcement we are also
working in partnership with the
communities most affected by this
violence
shortly president biden and i will be
meeting with leaders of the community
violence intervention program here in
new york
in 2021 the department provided over 37
million dollars in grant funding
directly to community violence
intervention efforts and we will expand
that work
in the year ahead
the justice department will use every
tool at our disposal to protect our
communities
we will hold perpetrators of violent
crime and gun violence accountable
we will work alongside the communities
most affected by that violence
and we will work together to build the
public trust
that is essential to public safety
before i close i want to note that in
times of crises
both large and small
the american people look to law
enforcement to help
and every day officers
like those who are with us here
answer the call
without hesitation
despite the difficulty
and the danger
they show up
and they put their lives on the line
that is what detective jason rivera
and detective wilbert mora did
there are no words
i can offer that could capture their
bravery
or the pain that has been inflicted on
their loved ones
what i can say is at the department of
justice we will seek to honor detectives
rivera and maura in the work we do
to help keep our law enforcement
officers safe
as we work to keep our communities safe
we'll now turn the program over to mayor
adams thank you
thank you so much uh attorney general
and
mr president it's it's really good
seeing you
and
uh how did we get here
uh when i was in washington d.c we were
in a meeting
and the president pulled me into the
oval office
and after
asking
what could he do for the city
and our desire to deal with violence
i had a brief nod and i was about to
walk out
and he grabbed me by my arm
and turned me around and looked into my
eyes
he says eric
what can we do
and i told him the help we needed
and i asked him several things but two
of them was one to come to new york
and to speak with our city state and
federal
law enforcement personnel so we could
have a 9 11 response to this violence we
came together as a country
when international terrorists decided to
change our way of life
and we responded
and the
response was the same
by this president
in august this room came together some
of the finest men and women in law
enforcement
and they meet every day
to zero in on the violence
that is attempting to take our way of
life
now thank you
for your response and mr president i
thank you for your response and then i
ask him to go on the ground
because it's about intervention and
prevention and prevention are the
long-term things we need to do
i ask him to go on the ground with us to
meet the crisis management teams the
everyday people who are doing the hard
work
in alignment with the police department
and today
we're going out to queensbridge and meet
that team a young man named haybane is
using his skills to bring down violence
and in his area we saw
zero homicides for a period of time
but it was not only because of what he
did it was because of what d.a katz did
to partner with him by bringing down
those known violent offenders
that's the combination we need
and i'm biased mr president
because i have some of the best
congressional delegations here in new
york
joining us today we have
the dean of the delegation that's here
congressman nadler we have congressman
hakeem jeffries
congressman congresswoman grace ming
congressman tom swazi
and we have the top attorney general
anywhere in this country an attorney
general letitia james and as you
indicated we have two of the best
u.s attorneys in the southern and
eastern district that's here with us we
were so proud to meet with them
yesterday but also a district attorney
team
as we see here katz
uh darcel clock
uh
mcmahon out in staten island and d.a
brads a real conservative and combined
effort to get this done
and then i think about congressman
esperiat
in his district
where where the two officers were slain
but also in his district
was where 11 month old baby was shot
while sitting by
her mother
also in his district was where 19 year
old child working in burger king was
shot and killed
and he was on the ground for each one of
those incidents standing with me as we
fought against this violence
the police commissioner and i are
dedicated and committed to turning this
around i made the best choice anyone can
make in picking a police commissioner
she's the right person at the right time
to do the right job and i'm proud to
serve with her
we know how important this is yesterday
we gathered at saint patrick's cathedral
in morning
today
here at one police plaza where i walked
across that stage as a captain
we're here in solidarity to deal with
the issue of violence that has become
pervasive in not only new york city but
in the cities across america and i want
to thank all of you for joining me as we
pursue this fight to make sure
the stain of violence does not destroy
our communities
the u.s attorney
general garland i appreciate your
commitment and dedication and living up
to the promise that was done with your
team as we sat in the room with
ambassador susan wright
and sitting there with the president and
other mayors across the city as we deal
with this issue
the president is here because he knows
what the american people wants
justice
safety and prosperity and they deserve
every bit of it
and he wants to end the gun violence in
our city
and in our country in the future built
on equality and opportunity because the
lack of the two feeds the gun violence
that we are seeing
far too often when we advocate for this
mr president people miss the part that
we state we want to end inequality
let's stop being divisive and united to
come together and deal with this fight
we are on the same page there is a
reader's reason they call me the biting
of brooklyn
that's what new yorkers want too
that's what i campaign on and it's why
you elected me as the mayor of the city
of new york it is what the president
came here today to hear from you and to
deliver
last week my administration released our
blueprint to end gun violence
there are many rivers as you stated
that feed the sea of violence we must
damn every river
one river will cause another death
prematurely in our city
and many reasons these rivers have
continued to rise in our city in our
country and we're going to stop them
from doing so
but the president and these leaders that
are here today
we are going to work together to end
this violence in our city and in our
country
when president biden and i first met
last summer
we hit it off right away we had a clear
mission the average joe they called him
because we know we have to build a city
in the country that's made up of
everyday
new yorkers in america
he knows that public safety and justice
are the bedrock of our economy our
democracy and our society
and we know who we work for
the people
and that includes
the dishwasher
people who wear coveralls aprons scrubs
and hard hats the everyday people who
just want to provide for their families
in one day
go from being a dishwasher a mail room
attendant and become a mayor of the city
of new york every day new yorkers and
everyday americans
the people who want to raise their
families in a city and in a country with
good jobs
good schools and safe streets
we both know our highest calling
our most important mission
is protecting the people of the city and
of this country
making sure they have what they need to
live their lives in safety
and helping them recover after two years
of the devastation of covet crisis and
violence
there is no recovery without public
safety there is no cover recovery
without justice they go hand in hand
that is why we're working in lockstep to
end the gun violence that has shaken our
city our nation to protect our people
and
the officers who sworn to protect us and
to restore the american dream of safety
stability and prosperity
that is why the president is here in new
york city
in this city today
you understand how serious this moment
is
we need as i stated a 9 11 type response
to address the domestic terror that is
pervasive in this city and country
and president biden is here to deliver
on his promise to come here he committed
to it and he is here
and get new york is the backup we need
far too long we called for backup and it
was not here it is time
to have that backup
this morning the white house announced
that the federal government would direct
more resources to fight local crime
around the country
expand the information sharing model
that you're going to witness here today
mr president
and call for more funding for congress
for violent interrupters something that
my congressional delegation understands
so clearly we could build back if we
pass build it back that is how we build
america back and scale up a nationwide
response to this public health crisis
that is gun violence that's why we're
here today
to bring together our federal state and
city partners in common cause we're
going to stop gun trafficking from
coming into our city get illegal guns
off the streets and lock up those who
carry them and make sure that they don't
leave prison or jails without the
opportunities they need so they don't
have a revolving door of crime in our
city and country
we're going to provide
funding for cities and state to put more
police officers in the places we need
them
invest in community violence prevention
and intervention programs and change our
laws to prevent crime and save lives and
do it in a way that we can disagree
without being disagreeable because we
are in this fight together
we're going to break and destroy the
iron pipeline that allows southern
states in this country to produce
weapons that end up on the streets and
take the lives of our police officers
maura and rivera
and i want to again take my off hat off
to officer
summit who protected countless numbers
of new yorkers and responding police
officers by taking the appropriate
action to end the threat that we were
facing
we're going to damn those rivers of
violence and address the sources of
those violence
it's about more than fighting crime
as congressman velasquez reminds us all
the time
it's about rebuilding our society
it's not just locking people up
it's about picking them up and giving
them the opportunity to do so
that is why the american people elected
joe biden to lead them
that is why we're willing to follow that
leadership
that is why i'm proud to be here today
among the men and women who wore that
same uniform that i wore to stand
shoulder to shoulder with the president
and we want to get
stuff
done
that's the administration
of the biden's administration and the
adams administration to get stuff done
for the american people
and mr president
eric adams is reporting for duty and
ready to serve
thank you i'm going to turn it over to
our governor
[Applause]
thank you mr president for
participating here today
um you hear me now
all right
all right
mr president
life is all about showing up
and on a day when you had a deal with an
intern a national incident
where the rest of the country was
riveted on the news that was coming out
of the white house
you still found the time to show up
and to me that is a commitment
that will not take for granted
it's more than just words
it's a sign of your desire to really be
a partner with all of us
as i am with the mayor of new york
and with our district attorneys and the
new york state police and the nypd who i
said today it is so refreshing not to
see you
sitting there
with tears in our eyes in st patrick's
cathedral as we have been doing far too
often so commissioner i want to thank
you for leading an incredible team i'm
proud of my team at the state level we
also have other state partners we have
our great attorney general leticia james
is here mr attorney general thank you we
think you're doing a great job with the
country we've got the all-star right
here in our own state as well as well as
all the elected officials who i had the
privilege of serving within congress a
decade ago
this is the team that has to be
activated because we cannot wait a
single day longer because the challenge
that lies before us it's not unique to
new york state it is not unique to this
city
is an american crisis but what we're
doing here in the state of new york and
the city of new york can be used as a
model
for other parts of our country to show
them what real collaboration looks like
i've been in this business a long time
and i've seen that people get into silos
federal government's got to handle this
case the prosecutors over here and the
local government district attorneys are
over here and the state government has a
different role for the first time in my
life i'm seeing
a unification
of purpose
that has been missing
and the ones who ought to be afraid of
that
are those who dare violate the laws that
are in place to protect the people of
our cities and our state
but also there are people
who are hurting in this community
we saw an incredible increase in
violence
immediately following the pandemic
it appears to me the human condition was
very frail we have people who succumb
to suicide
substance abuse domestic violence
and even yes
acquiring a gun on the streets for 1200
and using against one of their fellow
men or women
we have to figure out the root causes
here
and that is why in my budget
i not only triple the amount of money to
support
our law enforcement activities and
community policing but triple the amount
of money being spent on the exact kind
of programs we're all talking about here
is figuring out what is happening when
young people
are faced with that decision that's
going to affect them for the rest of
their lives do i stay on the straight
and narrow
or do i succumb to the streets
where am i going to find my family
we need to provide that family
and let them know that there are jobs
and opportunities and adults who care
about them and the violence disrupters
and i've seen them in action so many
times
many of them are former gang members
they're the ones who can speak to them
in a way that no one else can
so we're continuing to support that and
mr president i want to thank you for the
american recovery plan dollars
we are spending them on many important
causes but we are dedicating many of
them have you suggested to dealing with
both sides of the equation
the very human side we need to be
dealing with the resources and support
for these people but also those who
cross the line deal with that and make
sure our law enforcement have the
resources with respect to ghost guns i
signed a law just a few months ago that
banned them in the state of new york
and as a series of reforms
we also banned
the component parts and we named that
after an individual whose name i'm going
to say right now and that is scott j
beagle
he is the brave teacher in that school
in parkland where our children were
slaughtered his family is from long
island we named it after him and his
mother was there and gave me this hug
and said we'll never forget scott wilby
and i said never never ever
justice will remember
other victims the men and women like
officer
rivera and mora
who so proudly wear those uniforms to
hear from their families what it meant
to them to put on that uniform every day
it was so
impactful and powerful to hear their
words we have to fight to protect them
as well
so mr president we're gonna find all the
smart ways to double down on this
the task force that you reference has
already
worked together collaboratively nine
states
in addition to the state police nypd
your own atf has represented boston
police department these counties and
states have come together like never
before with one purpose
is to stop the flow of guns over our
borders because yes as governor i'm
going to help my mayors and i have
mayors all over the state who need my
help but my job is to protect those
borders because 80 percent
of guns in this state are coming from
other states illegally so i'm watching
those borders
let everybody be aware we are checking
we're out there we're checking the
people who are putting
guns in their trunks and gun shows in
pennsylvania heading north and ending up
in manhattan brooklyn the bronx cleans
staten island it's going to stop right
now
that is the message we have the
resources we have the will
we have the desire to get this done
because our citizens
are calling on us to protect them so
they can feel safe once again in this
great city and this incredible state so
mr president thank you for your time you
being here today sends a powerful
message and we do not forget that you
never forgot us at a time when we needed
your support the most
and with that i'd like to introduce an
incredible partner that we have
representing us the entire state in
washington d.c and that is our senator
kirsten gillibrand
thank you governor
um thank you for your leadership and
your determination to take this scourge
of gun violence head on it really does
matter i want to recognize all my state
partners
who are sitting here with me our
delegation and congress as well as our
da's and our attorney general i want to
thank each of you for being here
new york has just lost two officers who
were shot and killed in the line of duty
detective wilbert morris funeral was
yesterday
he was only 27.
last week i attended the funeral of
detective jason rivera
who was only 22.
they had their whole lives ahead of them
after that i stood with jennifer pryor
a mom who i first met in 2009.
her brilliant beautiful daughter
naija was an honor roll student and on
the cheerleading squad
one night when naija was out with her
friends celebrating their recent
graduation a stray bullet hit her in the
head and killed her instantly
i went to brooklyn
i met her family i met her classmates
losing a child that young is really hard
it's hard for the community and it's
hard for everyone
as a mom of two young boys who are about
that age right now
i can't imagine the horror
or the pain that a parent lives through
to keep going forward every day
and as a senator i made a commitment
that we would take action and do what we
could on the federal level to stop the
senseless gun violence in our cities in
our state and our country
new york is is not unique but it does
have a particular problem
almost 90 percent of the guns used in
crimes in our city are trafficked guns
just as the governor said
so our approach to combating gun
violence has to include dealing with
these trafficked weapons
right now there's literally no federal
law that makes it illegal to cross a
state line
with a trunk full of guns
get on a bus with a bag full of guns get
in your car and drive up the iron
pipeline and sell them directly out of
the back of a truck
into the arms of criminals in our city
we have to change that it's really
pretty simple we have to keep these
illegal guns off of our streets
out of the hands of those who could not
buy them legally
we have to work hand in glove across
federal state and local government lines
we have to pass the common-sense gun
reforms that the president talked about
that our mayor wants that our attorney
general fights for
we have strong partners here
i believe between all of us here to get
today we can do this
the bill that many of us have been
working on in washington is called the
hadia pendleton and aisha prior yard gun
trafficking crime prevention act which
would establish gun trafficking as a
federal crime
and go upstream to address all
responsible parties
the traffickers buying the guns and
transporting them across state lines
the gun dealers who knowingly facilitate
or recklessly disregard the warning
signs of gun trafficking
and the kingpins and organizers who plan
the trafficking
when similar lettuce legislation was
bought up in 2013 for a vote it got 58
votes
you know in the senate we have to get
60. it was the closest we got to any
common-sense gun reform
this is a gun that commissioner kelly
help this is a bill that commissioner
kelly helped me write
and so i know with our new police
commissioner and i know with our
governor and our mayor
and with our president we can get this
done this year
we cannot have more stories of
four-year-olds dying on park benches in
brooklyn
we cannot have more stories
of moms and their movement
speaking out
begging leaders to do what's right
we can do this and we will
now like to introduce hakeem jeffries
thank you senator gillibrand to
president biden mayor adams
governor hochul general garland
commissioner sewell all my colleagues
government men and women of
the nypd president biden thank you for
your leadership
your partnership for your presence
here in new york city
we believe the greatest
city in the world
with apologies to wilmington delaware
but every great city of course
has challenges
and
a stunning rise in gun violence is a
major challenge for us
to address but we recognize as you have
indicated it's a national
challenge
you think about the dynamic that we are
confronting here
in america we have four percent
of the world's
population
but 40
of the world's guns
that means there are more than 300
million guns circulating
in the united states of america
and many of those guns
such as the one
used to strike down
two heroes
detective rivera and detective mora are
weapons of war
they're not used to hunt deer they're
used to hunt
human beings that's not acceptable
many of those guns too easily fall into
the hands
of violent individuals
in far too many communities such as many
that i represent in central brooklyn and
across
america that's not acceptable and far
too many of those guns
are illegally trafficked from other
places
into
this great
metropolis that's not
acceptable
so it's an all hands on that
approach that will require tremendous
leadership as is being provided by our
president our governor and our mayor
and our congressional delegation
at all levels of government city state
and federal
and the congressional delegation in the
house representatives velasquez nadler
espana meng swazi and others we stand
ready to partner with you
to get done what needs
to happen
to deal with
this gun violent scourge with the fierce
urgency of now
to make sure that we balance the
interests of public safety
and that important american principle of
liberty and justice for all and invest
in communities that have traditionally
been left behind to create opportunity
in every single zip code a tough moment
for us in the city
but we're a resilient community a
resilient city a resilient country you
can knock us down but never knock us out
and together
we will get this done
thank you for your leadership mr
president
i now yield to my good friend
whose district we are in here in lower
manhattan congresswoman
nydia velazquez
well i don't know if you can hear me
good morning everyone thank you for
being here mr president it is such an
honor
and it is so comforting to the men and
women in uniform
to the mothers fathers
brothers sisters
who have suffered
because of gun violence in our country
to the attorney general garland
governor hockle
and mayor adams thank you for making it
possible but also in recognizing that it
takes all of us working together
to my new york
congressional delegation i want to
recognize the incredible role that we
have played in working together with
this administration to make sure that we
secure the resources not only to deal
with gun violence in our country but to
tackle the issue of the pandemic
to provide relief assistance to small
businesses in our country and i am proud
that we have been able to get this
economy growing again
that because of the commitment and
vision of president biden since the
start of the pandemic gun violence in
our city has searched two levels not
seen in a decade
shootings are up by 166 percent here in
new york city across the u.s over 20 000
people were killed by gun violence last
year
black and brown communities
we are victims of gun violence it takes
us
also because we are on the ground we
know what works and what doesn't work
we got the expertise and we need to use
all those graphs grassroots community
organization who understand the dynamics
that play into
gun violence in our country
so these statistics are not just numbers
each represents a lost member of our
communities we must recognize that
mobilizing community-based resources
job opportunities and early intervention
are key to protecting our youth from gun
violence we must post once and for all
on the iron thailand
of illegal guns being funneled into
states like new york
this is just not a public safety issue
but one
that require partnerships
with health care institutions school
job creating programs churches as hakim
jeffrey just said we are all
hands and deck this is how we're going
to tackle this issue and i want to
recognize
los ures anti-violence program
in north brooklyn working with
nycha new york city housing public
authority and they are working to stem
the gun violence issue in public housing
they have been successful it is proven
it can work let's do it thank you
and it's my honor to introduce the
chairman of the judiciary committee
chairman jerry nadler
well thank you very much
i obviously agree with everything that's
been said and i certainly
thank the president
uh for his support
uh for the actions he's taking to bring
money to new york for his support of
legislation
in order to solve this problem
you know it is said that um
by the nra
and i remember 19 in 2004 when we passed
uh when a republican congress passed
that bill to exempt
gun manufacturers from lawsuits because
they were being sued on the model of the
um
tobacco companies
who had been who had been
sued
for
falsifying the information about the
toxicity of their product
and they managed to pass this
legislation which is still on the books
and
the president was then a senator
was instrumental in 1994 in getting the
assault weapons ban passed
it was a 10-year bill
and it was it was allowed to expire in
2004 and i wish we could get it back
legislation that we have passed
in congress
is wholly inadequate
now the judiciary committee
has passed
the house has passed two bills
hr8
which requires a background check on
every gun or transfer with limited
exceptions
such as family members
we passed
the enhanced background checks act of
2021
last march
which addresses the charleston loophole
in background check procedures
this loophole is that when an individual
attempts to purchase a firearm from a
licensed dealer the fbi has three days
to complete a background check and if
the background check isn't completed in
three days he gets the gun
even if
even if the background check would come
back in four or five days and say that
this person is a dangerous person to
have the gun
so we passed the
enhanced background checks act of of
2021
which allowed which
addresses this deficiency by providing
the fbi additional time to complete
background checks here's notice of the
fbi about which cases need to be
prioritized for review
and
the judiciary committee
in uh
october of last year only a few months
ago reported favorably out of committee
uh lucy mcbass bill
uh a
red flag bill
which would create a federal extreme
risk or red flag law as we call it that
would prevent firearms from being
accessible to those who are a danger to
themselves and others
the bill would create procedures for
federal courts
to issue extreme risk protection orders
to prohibit a person from purchasing
possessing or receiving a firearm or a
firearm or ammunition
under the bill a family or household
member or a law enforcement officer can
petition
the court for an extreme risk protection
order with respect to an individual
who poses a risk themselves or others
the bill also adds people who are
subject to an extremist protection order
to the categories of persons prohibited
from purchasing shipping
transporting possessing or receiving a
firearm or ammunition
under federal law
now in the last congress in 116th
congress the senate companion to this
bill was introduced by lindsey graham
the concept was championed by
none other than president trump in a
series of 2019 statements on mass
shootings
senator graham has not reintroduced the
bill yet in 117th congress but we're
talking to him
leadership has expressed support
given its bipartisan origins and
outreach by representative mcmath and
others by committee staff
the bill we hope will find republican
support of the house floor
and
i believe
that this bill
is the best hope for legislative action
on gun violence and what remains of this
congress
now of course
this is wholly inadequate
um and that's why everything the
president is talking about the attorney
general is talking about doing by
executive order which should be law
but we haven't been able to make it law
should be done by executive order and
hopefully
eventually by law
thank you thank you so much of
the entire congressional delegation
we want to uh now
i know the police commissioner has to
depart to go to the walkout for one of
the officers that was shot a few nights
ago
police commissioner if you want to say a
few comments and then we'll turn it over
to the task force
to give a presentation on what they're
doing every day
thank you mr mayor
mr president attorney general garland
thank you so much for coming to witness
firsthand what the nypd and all law
enforcement partners are doing to end
the proliferation of illegal guns and
shootings in new york city
we know across the cities and major
areas in this country they're
experiencing an uptick in violence a
growing number of shootings and guns on
their streets in new york city has not
been immune
experts will lightly debate this for
years but we do not have years
there are too many people carrying guns
who are not afraid to use them
our officers are out there engaging and
they are doing what literally is the
most dangerous thing a police officer
can do
they are taking guns out of the hands of
criminals on our streets
and our officers are paying a heavy
price for it
it cannot be overstated that since the
beginning of the year we have had six of
our own officers shot
and tragically two of them killed
and mr president and attorney general
garland i want to thank you for your
outpouring of support and your
condolences during this time during the
loss of our members it's sincerely
appreciated
in fact again as the mayor said we have
to excuse ourselves because a little bit
of good news one of our officers is
being released from the hospital today
so we're going to head over there
despite a record number of gun arrests
and seizures by the police the
communities and our citizens continue to
pay a horrific price
we've seen our citizens suffer from this
violence
bystanders unintended targets babies and
people simply trying to do their jobs
we know this violence is not acceptable
against our citizens or our police
officers
and we know that it has to be stopped
and we know that it starts here in the
nypd with action
that is why the gun violence strategies
partnership was started
what you are seeing here today mr
president is every component of law
enforcement in new york literally at the
table
this morning we're gonna do what this
group does every day
we're gonna go over the shootings the
suspects the guns the shell casings the
facts
to connect the dots
they will go around the table we're
going to use every tool talent and
resource available through every
agencies to focus on the very few
who are responsible for the largest
number of shootings in our city
and we intend to use every legal tool at
our disposal to remove them from our
communities
this is about the life of a city
but it's also about the lives of the
people who make up this city
and together with this partnership we
know that we will not fail it's an
extraordinary meeting i've been a part
of it these are truly professionals and
i want to turn it over to deputy
commissioner chauncey parker who's
basically like the quarterback of this
team
because this is sensitive information
that is shared
and so if personnel could help us
uh